okay so let's now talk about the
Democratic Party and the Iowa State
Democratic Party the timing of this
could not be worse but the reputation of
the Democratic Party is in shambles
after the absolute fiasco of Monday
night's Iowa caucus now there are
essentially two sides to this and I
alluded to this earlier there are people
who are saying this is nothing other
than a technical snafu it's good that it
happened early in Iowa in the first
caucus rather than you know at some
later point we can now prevent it from
happening again
I believe it's Nevada that was scheduled
to use the same app or tech system for
their upcoming a vote and now they are
deciding not to because of what happened
in Iowa okay that's one side it's a
technical snafu and the timing of it is
really bad the other side has gone into
more conspiratorial stuff and I don't
say that pejoratively the there's a
definition for what a conspiracy would
be and there are the gist of it is that
it links everything that happened on
Monday to a DNC Pete Budaj edge
consultant conspiracy mostly to deny
Bernie Sanders the nomination that there
are variations there are different
flavors of the conspiracy theory but
that's roughly the gist of it so what's
important is very often people fall for
a conspiracy theory merely because the
motive seems to check out absent
anything else so let's just break it
down piece by piece and we shouldn't be
afraid to do this this is not out of
hand dismissing a conspiracy but it is
also not irrationally feeding it the
first part is motive there is no doubt
that the DNC and the establishment does
wanna deny Bernie Sanders the nomination
we've been seeing countless examples of
how that this manifests very early on
there were stopped Bernie meetings Pete
Budaj edge was part of those meetings we
are seeing Hillary Clinton reappear more
and more in the public spotlight very
often to criticize Bernie on the Howard
Stern Show in that recent docu-series
on the recent podcast whose name escapes
me but I talked to you about on Monday
so there's no question that there is an
establishment effort to try to prevent
Bernie Sanders from being the nominee
that's not really the focus of the
Monday Fiasco I tend to arrange
hypotheses from simplest to most complex
the conspiracy theories about Iowa while
possible seem less likely to me than
what we know to be true which is
unfortunately most people aren't good at
their jobs incompetence is everywhere
the 80/20 rule tells us about this
Hanlan's raiser tells us not to
attribute to malice what can be
appropriately attributed to incompetence
or ignorance that still is the most
likely scenario to me but importantly
and I'm trying to do this more and more
since reading Annie Dukes book thinking
and bets when I say I think it's more
likely that this is incompetence rather
than a conspiracy I'm not saying that
it's 100 percent right what I am saying
is that if I had to bet I believe it is
more likely that this is incompetence
and not a conspiracy we should talk more
in these terms none of us know for sure
but if you said to me what would what
would my return have to be on a dollar
bet for me to bet that it's a conspiracy
versus that it is merely incompetence I
would need a bigger return on the
conspiracy bet in order to make it
because I think it is less likely if the
Iowa Democratic Party was going to
rigged the results wouldn't they rigged
it so that the person who gets the most
delegates would also get the most number
of votes because when we looked at the
reports of voting as of right now with
71% reporting this may have changed by
the time that that you guys watch this
clip or listen to today's show Bernie
Sanders has more raw votes but Pete
Budaj edge has more delegates that is
creating way more questions it is
getting people fired up it is getting
people saying this is just like Trump
winning the electoral college but losing
the popular vote Bernie had more votes
Bernie should have more delegates if
they were rigging it they would rigged
it so that the total vote count also
favors Pete Budaj edge if that was the
point of this entire
now as far as the DNC being in shambles
Nathan Robinson wrote a piece in The
Guardian where he says it is a technical
snafu but it is a technical snafu that
could not have come at a worse time and
it is the technical snafu which directly
helps some people and directly hurts
some people the setup is 2016 where the
DNC was widely slammed for putting their
thumb on the scale for Hillary against
Bernie Sanders this includes
super-delegates this includes the
initial scheduling of debates including
like on a Sunday night on a three-day
weekend
which just hurts any challenger and
reinforces the de facto frontrunner the
whole story you likely are familiar with
from 2016 so since 2016 there's been
this question of well what is the DNC
going to do this time are they going to
play more fair they did the right thing
by removing super delegate voting from
the first round at the DNC I don't want
to rehash the details of that but that
makes the process more democratic but
suspicions were still high going into
2020 and the primary that things were
not going to be totally on the up-and-up
and very quickly we started seeing
Hillary Clinton jump in to slam Bernie
at a number of different opportunities
there are discussions happening in the
the basements and back hallways of the
DNC about well maybe we push super
delegate voting back to the first round
at the DNC debate qualification rules
are being changed to potentially allow
Michael Bloomberg into the debates which
is again not something that is going to
help Bernie Sanders so in short tensions
are running super high and this is the
exact time that the DNC should not fail
and Monday they failed their entire tech
system for the Iowa caucus failed there
are people saying well it's more the
Iowa Democratic Party not the DNC this
is perceived as all part of the same
apparatus and it looks terrible the DNC
comes away looking incompetent changing
rules a failing app unable to report
report results at exactly a time when
many Americans are considering do I stay
home do I vote for Trump I don't really
like Trump but the DNC seems like it's
in over its head and then you read about
the DNC
failing miserably and embarrassingly at
the first opportunity to count votes the
optics are a train wreck and by the way
the coin flips for the uneven delegate
counts in Iowa I get why it's done this
way I understand that the meaning of one
delegate in one precinct is tiny tiny
tiny but when you're selecting who's
going to run against Donald Trump you
are just opening yourself up to
criticism and ridicule by using coin
flips to decide about Delegates now that
this happened who is going to trust the
DNC to run primaries for the rest of the
election and just as importantly Donald
Trump and the right have been trying to
frame the DNC as exactly this Trump and
the right have been saying the DNC is
incompetent
the DNC can't run an election the DNC is
trying to screw Bernie again they're
unable to get out of their own way and
the DNC hands Trump a goldmine of fodder
and on Monday night Donald Trump within
minutes of this Fiasco was tweeting
about it like we went through on
yesterday's show it's a comedy of errors
and it all is another little push
towards the outcome of a trump
reelection we'll talk about very good
poll numbers for Trump on the bonus show
today and also on tomorrow's program but
this could not have come at a worse time
for the deaf for the Democratic Party